foreign
get ready everybody this is everybody's
favorite segment
facts are your friends here come the
tunes
get your bandanas and climb into the
Camaros with this rock tunes
this is like straight marble Reds
nothing else
just OG in a camo hat Joe's rocking a
camo hat it's a it's perfect all right
back to your friends
2023 dating Trends revealed now it's
important for me to note
I haven't dated in a long long time
several years ago I was back in Texas
and a buddy of mine had was divorced and
was dating again and so we were out to
lunch having a burger
and I was like all right dude I kind of
live it vicariously like what's it like
man you're like back out there what's it
like
I'll never forget man
uh he leaned across the table
and his eyes got kind of narrow like
lasered in and he said
I don't care what's happening in your
marriage figure it out
it's terrible out here and I started
laughing I was like what are you talking
about and he's like remember back in
college when you would see somebody like
you know out somewhere at some event or
you're like all hanging out whatever and
you saw somebody you thought they're
cute and you went up to him you're like
hey I'm John and uh what if I get like
what's your name and can I buy a drink
or you know come sit with our buddies
you and your friends want to come over
he's like if you do that now it's
stalking they will call somebody on you
or they will like like cut eyes at
security and ask you to leave you can't
do that anymore you gotta go get
somebody's uh social information and
then stalk them for days or weeks online
and you just bypass the first one
through nine dates by I don't need to
ask you what your favorite music is I
just look through your your Instagram
reel and look at all the concerts you've
been to and all the shirts you wear like
all I get all your fashion I get all the
things you're into all your friends and
then after that you go on your first
date and then you just make out and so
he was like dude the whole thing the
whole thing's crazy it's all different
now and so I decided I was gonna work on
my marriage and so here we are 2023
years later dating Trends revealed this
is from dating.com
that sounds like a reliable source says
this data says resolution dating
inflation and metaverse dating
oh God Almighty we'll Define online
dating in 2023
the article says
um there's not there's not an author
here it just says uh Yahoo finance
singles are looking for partners who
help them stay true to their own New
Year's resolutions singles are
continuing to rely on technology to make
new connections and to build
relationships so I could see that like
if you or somebody you know we talk
about
um I'm going to create some new
identities and then I'm going to
backfill my new identity with actions
that lead me towards all right so I'm a
fit person I'm a person who takes care
of my body I'm going to date somebody
that maybe wants to go work out with me
or go hiking with me or go for walks
um or somebody that if I say hey I'm
going to I'm gonna get a burger without
the bun they're not like oh my gosh
I'm gonna date somebody that's going to
lead me towards my goals that makes
sense to me
um and singles are continued around rely
on technology to make new connections
and to build relationships I call
bullcrap on a stick in a box on the back
of a pony riding through the desert on
that one I think that's not true we'll
get to that later
um it goes on to say in doing so the
goal is to find a partner that aligns
with and supports your own personal
goals whether they're related to your
career Fitness hobby or new skills that
you want to learn
here's what I'm it makes me
uncomfortable about this
anytime you are making changes you're
working towards goals let's say you want
to run a marathon training for a
marathon it's awful it's just long runs
right sometimes it's cold sometimes it's
hot sometimes the runs are awesome and
they feel great but it's training's hard
right
um getting out of debt is hard I have to
say no to everything and put all this
money I'm making and I'm working side
hustles and extra jobs all that money is
going to pay a credit card off for
something I bought a year ago or five
years ago or a college class I took 10
years ago right so accomplishing a goal
is hard and when you
meet somebody and you and and their
current version of themself aligns and
supports your own personal goals it
becomes utilitarian I'm gonna align with
you because you are going to help me get
to where I want to go and as I'm going
there it's going to be uncomfortable and
I my fear here is I'm going to project
my discomfort onto you and so I know
it's a balance right you don't want to
meet somebody you don't want to date
somebody who's
um vision for their life doesn't align
with you at all but this is a lot of
pressure to put on a new person that
you're just meeting and the chances of
you
getting frustrated along the way as you
become somebody who I'm a vice president
kind of guy so I'm gonna start doing
vice president kind of things that's
awkward and hard as you make that
transition and it's real easy if you are
leaning on somebody that they get the
brunt of the discomfort they become a
source of blame or frustration
um 55 percent of respondents rated
common goals and values is more
important than physical appearance and
attraction
looks like we're growing up okay then we
went to uh resolution dating sixty
percent
um noted that they would pump the brakes
on a relationship if the partner's
behaviors or habits were hindering them
from reaching Fitness and Wellness goals
I don't understand that
mainly
I guess I do I guess I do I guess if
every time I worked out my wife was like
you're the worst I hate you I that
probably wouldn't pode well or if I
wanted to eat healthy and she was like
more marshmallows that probably wouldn't
go well either
um here's my concern so
when I started uh grad school my wife
and I were both in graduate school at
the same time and let me back up when I
was a kid my mom went back to college
late in life and she is a mythologist so
she was studying mythology and she was
she learned Old English and she was
reading some of these original
Shakespearean texts and their old
original language all this stuff so my
mom is all into this and I was like 16
17. and I'd be watching like the Astros
and my mom would get in front of the TV
and mute it and be like you guys gotta
listen to this and she would read us
something in Old Shakespearean Old
English or Middle English I don't know
what Shakespeare's written in and she
was dying laughing like it was some
great inside joke in King Lear that I
didn't get as a 16 year old and I
remember being like Oh my gosh this is
ridiculous and I also very clearly
remember my mom was in heaven she loved
it so fast forward my wife and I are in
grad school
I remember like one day we were out to
dinner and I was like Hey listen I'm
studying student development theory and
how colleges operate you are studying
reading literacy and how children's
brains learn to read I will never ever
care about that and you are never going
to care about what I'm studying could we
just make a deal now that we will never
talk about what the other person's
studying could that would that be
amazing and I thought she was going to
weep with joy she was so excited she's
like oh God yes I hate talking to you
about whatever this nonsense you want to
talk about and so we made an agreement
there like let's just not ever talk
about it and then over the years
like we shared a laptop for a long time
before everybody had their own laptop
and I would open up the laptop and she'd
be working on an academic paper she was
sending for publication and I would read
a page or two and I remember being like
who are you how do you know all this
stuff she's amazing and over the years
I've realized I think that was a mistake
I think I screwed that up then fast
forward to now I'm in a totally new
industry I'm learning about mental
health issues of talking to hundreds if
not thousands of people every week and
um or for show listeners dozens right
there's only like 18 of you out there
um and so
I just had a conversation with her uh
about a few weeks ago said hey we made
this deal a long time ago
I want to be able to talk to you about
my work and I want to hear about what
you're working on and the things you're
experiencing and so we are having to
learn how
to meet different needs as we've moved
our relationship on so why am I telling
you all that
it's if you're dating somebody
if you say like this person is going to
help me meet my goals and needs what
happens over time if those goals and
needs change and so I want you to
obviously focus on somebody's going to
help you with your with your goals and
ease and not lean on them too much like
we talked about earlier but also
be willing to be with somebody look for
somebody who is holds the world very
Loosely has some very strong core values
convictions but holds beliefs and other
things very loosely
man I was a vegan at one time and then I
was full keto one time and now I've got
more I I've developed a a different
protocol that works better for me and
don't come after me vegan and keto
people
but I'm a person that likes to say I was
wrong and I like to find out when I was
wrong I like to change my mind and my
wife is too and so more important than
being with somebody who helped me meet
my immediate goals I'm with somebody who
supports me wherever I head off into the
woods and who's walking alongside me and
I do the same
and our religious beliefs have diverged
over time our political beliefs have
diverged over time we've changed we've
become different people in multiple
different Arenas and so if you're
looking for someone like I'm a fitness
person and I only will date a fitness
person that's cool but there may come a
day
when going to CrossFit seven times a
week turns into I've got two little kids
and a full-time job and I've got a small
little home gym where I crank out 40
minutes four or five times a week that's
what I can get done
and if those people I only were CrossFit
people then you're gonna have some real
problems and so I want people to
resolution dating cool
um that seems very short-sighted
um tight budget means monogamy I love
this
61 of singles are opting to date one
person at a time versus meeting multiple
potential Partners simply to save money
on first dates
way to go America
um transitional dating 33 of singles
plan to date in the okay listen listen
this is the one that gives me
hemorrhoids
33 of singles plan to date in the
metaverse
in the metaverse
that's not real
that's not a thing
here's the thing about the metaverse
it's not real
uh using avatars to put a bigger
emphasis on communication and I love
this digital intimacy before in-person
discovery
few things in the world give me the
heebie-jeebies more than the phrase
digital intimacy
I can't recommend against this enough so
I want you to go on a thought experiment
with me
up until all of human history up until
the invention of the radio
and then fast forward to podcast
I talked to callers live callers on the
show and we have back and forth we talk
about intimate things and deep things
and we're having a human interaction
up until all human history until just
recently like a snapshot 100 years 200
years
you had to be in the room with a group
of people
to have this level of insight into these
intimate conversations
someone could relay them to you but you
couldn't hear them live and now we have
podcasts and earbuds and you can be
vacuuming
having a ringside seat to a conversation
that in all of human history you would
not have been able to have access to up
until just now
similarly like think of photographs
our brains are not wired to see pictures
of ourselves when we were five that is
brand stinking new
and so
we have the illusion of
intimacy and I know this because I talk
to people out in the in airports and at
Live Events and people will come up and
tell me things about their husbands or
their spouses or their sex life and I
often will go
whoa I don't know you like you're
telling me a lot and we're in a public
place I was peeing at an airport in an
airport bathroom
and a dude came to the stall next to me
I'm peeing I'm just looking at the tile
ahead of me like you're supposed to no
eye contact don't be weird just looking
at the tile
and the guy I guess looked over and was
like Hey you do John deloney and I was
like yeah man I'm peeing
and he goes dude I love your show
still peeing and then he goes
hey man so my wife and I just stopped I
stopped him and I was like hey man it's
not a good time and he goes oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
and here's the thing
his body
knows it was like has his body
understands that we are friends that we
have a connection
because he listens to the show he knows
about my kids he knows what makes me
laugh he knows our J my jokes he knows
how stupid I could be and how like not
good at Radio I am and how good at
podcasting him he knows all those things
because he's internalized him and his
body has this false sense of it
connection it's not real it's not real
it is real but it's not real so I tell
you this to
don't date in the metaverse
because
you can transmit information digitally
I can transmit the words I love you I
can transmit pictures of my naked body I
can transmit pictures of my home and my
childhood I can send you info
but our bodies are co-regulated I only
know where I am in space because there's
another living being in my presence
and so this it creates this Mass
illusion that's not real in different
parts of your body think it's connected
and other parts don't and we are
dude we are dancing on the nuclear
buttons when it comes to our physiology
combined with technology combined with
their neurology and psychology it's
Madness
so I cannot tell you I can't tell you
enough
don't date on the metaverse
if you play Legends of Zelda dude the
game's rad it's cool play Zelda
get out of the metaverse and find ways
even if you got to use an app to swipe
right swipe left whatever
connect with real people in the real
world
you owe it to your body I'll say it this
way there's no such thing as digital
intimacy it's not real
it's not real have human intimacy so
that's the uh 2023 dating trends
oh gosh Kelly this just makes me sad
good luck everybody